so I want to start this recap by wishing
a very very happy Birthday to Hannah if
you're watching hopefully you know who
you are if you're not Hannah and you're
watching wish Hannah a happy birthday in
the comments so let's get to my round s
recap I just played a really hard fought
game against Ravi Tesa from India uh
pretty strong International master and
coming into this game I was expecting a
kocon and my opponent did not surpr Ur
me but I did surprise my opponent and I
actually played a line here that I don't
think I've ever played in my life and it
starts with the classical variation
Knight C3 uh usually I like to play the
two knights attack Knight F3 and Knight
C3 I do have a video on YouTube how to
crush the kokan with the two knights
attack but I played um probably what's
one of the most popular lines against a
Caron after takes takes uh there's two
main lines black can play in this
position there is Bishop F5 and Knight
to F6 and this morning I Was preparing
against both of these moves uh but my
opponent chose Bishop F5 which um yeah
is I think the still the classical main
line I play Knight G3 he plays Bishop G6
I play H4 he plays H6 and then I play
Knight to F3 now I believe check with
the Master's database but I do believe
ah Knight F3 is still the most common
move and after Knight D7 yeah so here H5
is a main line but I choose to play a
secondary line actually the uh the
secondary move which is only played 5%
of the time which is Bishop to
D3 uh now there are some small nuances
because usually the main line is H5
Bishop H7 and then Bishop D3 and then
the bishops get traded so the main
difference is is having the pawn on H4
versus H5 and in my game I kept the pawn
on H4 and after takes takes this
position is a bit less common compared
to the main line and the reason for
having the pawn on H4 is something we'll
see a bit later on um hopefully it will
make sense within uh about 10 moves why
I want the pawn on H4 rather than H5 so
going forward from here my opponent
plays E6 I play Bishop f
and he plays Queen to A5 check and this
position was on my computer right before
the game and uh I was prepared with
Bishop to D2 and here the only move I
looked at for black is Queen to C7 I
thought this is the main point of
playing Queen A5 then dropping back to
um kind of displace my bishop and then
follow through with uh Bishop to D6 and
I had in mind a game uh that nepom nchi
played against some lower rated player
and if my opponent went for Queen C7 I
was going to Castle and the nepo game
went Bishop
D6 Knight E4 Bishop F4 let's see if uh
the game is in the Master's
database I'm pretty sure nepo had this
position and missed Queen A3 I might be
wrong about that but the one game does
show Queen A3 and I'm pretty sure Queen
A3 is the strongest move uh idea being
that once this bishop is traded then
Knight D6 will come and white should be
significantly better so this didn't
quite happen the game because instead of
Queen C7 my opponent played Bishop to
B4 now I just showed that variation
because I had it in mind here that I can
still try and exploit this D6 Square
especially now because the Bishops are
um almost guaranteed to get traded uh
now C3 is a natural looking move but
then black can drop back to E7 or D6 so
I went for the move which I thought was
the most aggressive and also just the
most venomous which is Knight E4 um now
I'm threatening to play Knight D6
because the bishop on B4 is pinned to
the queen uh so my opponent takes I take
back with my f Knight so still
threatening Knight to D6 and then my
opponent plays Knight F6 and just allows
me to get in this check and take away
casting rights I was actually kind of
surprised because my opponent played
this very quickly so I wasn't sure if he
was like still in some sort of
preparation or if he had calculated this
back from when he played uh Bishop B4
because he did take about 11 minutes to
play this
move but basically we got to this
position and then I was taking my time
like do I actually want to go for Knight
D6
and I ultimately did play Knight D6 uh
he played King E7 so it's somewhat of a
worse Bond Cloud black is not castling
this game and now I have a choice do I
want to take this pawn and uh I pretty
quickly arrived at the conclusion that
this Pawn is not worth taking because
yeah black will get some counterplay I
think Queen B4 was the move I was most
afraid of and then yeah there's cases
where B2 hangs where my knight just gets
stuck so uh instead of Knight takes B7 I
play Knight to
C4 um I'm actually really curious uh
about this move not at all like chess
wise but about notation wise because
when I played this move my opponent
wrote on his score sheets Knight 6 to C4
and I wrote on my score sheet Knight to
C4 um because my knight at D2 is pinned
so I'm curious what liess will say
yeah Lees says Knight C4 um I'm happy I
saved the extra energy writing uh Knight
C4 and discarding the six um anyway yeah
Knight C4 it's a nice Square attacking
the queen uring B2 is defended also in
some cases rerouting to E5 or E3 so here
my opponent plays Queen C7 and I Castle
Queen side and I was feeling good here
especially because Black's King is on E7
and it seems like I have a slightly more
harmonious setup even though my Knights
are maybe a little bit weird looking uh
this King on E7 definitely seems like a
a clear Target going into the middle
game and here my opponent played I think
a very sensible move Rook H2 d8 uh
basically preparing to tuck away the
King on f8 and essentially artificial
castle and in this position I took a bit
of a think trying to figure out what is
my plan and I really wanted to get in
this move Pawn G4 so I was considering
moves like Rook to G1 or Knight E3 or
queen F3 to prepare Pawn G4 and after a
bit of thinking I realized I can just
play G4 without really supporting it um
and ultimately I did just play Pawn G4
now this is a Pawn sacrifice but I don't
think it's good if black takes it
because then I would play Rook to G1
actually sacking another Pawn here but
the point is now Queen A3 check and I'm
going to have time to play Rook F1 next
move so for example C5 Rook F1 and the
knight's basically trapped uh there was
a brief moment I thought black could
play Knight H3 but then I realized my
queen still controls H3 so I think white
is in very very good shape if we were to
go into that line so going back I was
very happy to get in this move and play
it where it doesn't seem like black can
take it and this move uh basically
explains why I didn't play
H5 earlier is there are cases where the
H Pawn will support this G5 break
especially because black has committed
to H6 um so G5 is actually a very
significant threat and if I can play
this move and kick away the Knight and
maybe open the H file or the G file I
thought my prospects for attacking
Black's King are very very good with
King not really having a long-term safe
place so after I played G4 my opponent
took a long think and he played Pawn to
B5 after what about 20 minutes of
thinking and I drop back to E3 so I was
happy to have my Knight here supporting
the pawn and also there are some cases
uh where I can maybe set up Knight F5 uh
but here my opponent plays Queen to F4
so active move attacking the pawn
aligning with my king also pressuring
the D4 Pawn I respond with Queen to A3
check and I was still feeling good um I
still have initiative and my opponent
took another think here because there
are a few different moves to consider
between Pawn to C5 and queen D6 and King
E8
and there is one line that excited me if
he were to play Queen D6 which he didn't
actually play in the game I was going to
play G5 with idea that if takes I can
take with check so Knight would have to
move if we throw in takes takes here
there's some crazy line where I think I
can play Knight F5 after takes and Rook
E1 and basically the if the king moves
and I win the queen for free and then
otherwise a knight has to block and I'll
take with check I thought this looked
very good for me so that might explain
why my opponent didn't play Queen D6 but
rather played King to
E8 and um I thought this was a good
success because now the king is stuck in
the center my queen is piercing through
on the dark Spurs and I follow up with
Pawn to G5 as feeling very good here cuz
if black takes I would take back and
then Rook h8 is a massive threat so the
pawn can't really be taken uh he played
Knight to D5 I take on H6 he takes back
with Pawn I was expecting Queen H6 uh
after which I think maybe Knight E4
would come but Pawn takes was a slight
surprise um and this does fully open the
G file so I pretty quickly played Rook
to G1 threatening Rook G8 and he defends
with Knight to
F6 and in this position I wasn't
entirely sure what the best followup is
um but I I tried to keep the initiative
I played Queen to C5 attacking the
undefended pawn and then after Queen to
D6 we actually end up simplifying a bit
because I didn't see anything better
than to trade queens and after Rook
takes D6 I had a cool idea in mind to
play this move Knight to E4 where it
looks like my knight is just hanging but
if black takes it then I'm the one
winning material because black get
skewered on the eighth rank so Knight E4
essentially forces a rook back to
d8 and when I went for this line I was
originally planning to take on D5 uh
because the Knight would have to take
back I was thinking about Rook G7 but
then I wasn't sure if I actually have
anything after King E7 and Rook G8
coming so in this position I took some
time and realized I have another option
is to take the Knight on F6 and after he
took back I played the move Pawn to F4
and I like this idea of trying to get in
this F5 move Essen to trade off my
isolated F Pawn and basically leave
black with an isolated Pawn of his own
so after I play F4 uh he took a bit of a
think and plays King to
E7 and it's clear that he wants to get
the Rook to the G file and here I decide
that the G file isn't so useful for me
like Rook G7 is easily met with Rook G8
so I shift over to the E file Rook G to
E1 and now I'm threatening Knight F5 at
least I thought I was threatening Knight
F5 I don't know if I'm actually
threatening to take the pawn there are
cases where my knight would get trapped
but I thought it's nice to align The
Rook with the black king and either
Knight F5 or Pawn F5 are both in the air
so here my opponent plays Pawn to H5
which is a sensible positional move
trying to get the G4 Square potentially
for the Knight and I respond with Pawn
F5 and he plays Rook to D6 so
reinforcing E6 and here I really wished
I could have taken my own Pawn like kind
of some self cannibalism um but
unfortunately that's not allowed Knight
F5 would be a nice uh pin plus Fork
would have been a nice pork but not
quite a legal move so I end up going for
Pawn takes pawn and after he takes back
with Rook now I play Knight F5 now this
isn't quite a fork but I thought I'm
making progress CU after he plays King
to D7 I play Rook E5 I was happy to get
uh what we call a collinear move moving
along the same line as my OPP's Rook but
not actually taking the rook and my idea
here was I really wanted to pressure the
H Pawn and I thought that either Knight
G7 or Knight G3 are some nice follow-ups
uh to get another attacker against H5
and I also thought that in the event of
takes takes then of course I unleash the
Rook I attack the Knight and then I
thought that okay when the Knight
eventually moves I'll more easily be
able to exploit the pawn but I think
here my opponent played pretty precisely
and he did take on E5 with idea after I
take back he has Knight to
D5 and I was still feeling good because
I I played this move Knight to G7 and I
thought this is a really nice move
preventing King E6 attacking the pawn
and if he defends the pawn I was going
to play Rook to F1 attacking the F7 pawn
and preparing Rook F5 and I thought if
we go into this line King E7 Rook F5
then white has very good chances to win
the game because H5 is just hanging
there's no way for black to defend but
my opponent instead of playing Rook h8
played Rook G8 just gives me the pawn
and then plays King E6 in this position
and um yeah pretty quickly I realized
that just losing the pawn back there's
no hope in Saving both E5 and H4 like if
I play Rook E1 he's going to have
something like Rook h8 so here I decide
to simplify I play Knight F6 and after
Rook h8 I take on D5 he takes and I play
Rook to F1 and going forward from here
uh things simplify even further after
Rook H7 I play A4 he takes I play Rook
F4 uh defending and attacking and then
pawns begin to come off the board after
King takes E5 Rook takes A4 he plays F5
King D2 F4 uh it does look like he's
winning this Pawn but whenever he takes
the pawn then A7 will be hanging so we
played a few more moves King E2 Rook C7
C3 Rook B7 I play King F3 more pawns
come off and after Rook H2 Rook E7 King
F6 he offered the draw and I agreed and
another game ends peacefully after what
I think was a very interesting battle
and I don't think I was ever in like
trouble this game but I'm super curious
if I had chances
to push more for a win so as usual I'm
going to check with the engine I have
not checked at all with stockfish so far
so let me switch the chapter here enable
and let's make sure people can
[Music]
see so not a perfect game apparently we
each made one
inaccuracy uh let's just go back so in
the first several moves were all opening
Theory we were following some grandmas
games okay Bishop B4 is a playable
move and yeah 94 is maybe one of the
most testing
responses interesting
so so Bishop takes D2 was perhaps a
small novelty but still a very playable
move and then going forward from here I
do see the small blip in the graph so
what was my chance G4 best
move interesting so Knight takes G4 was
a better option for
black yeah this looks terrifying for
black Rook takes
G7 and stockfish slightly prefers this
line but I think this would be uh very
difficult for black to
defend so after
B5 this was Black's inaccuracy so what
was my inaccuracy
ah in this position Queen
A3 Queen A3 is one of the best moves I
didn't I don't think I even considered
Rook H3 it's interesting idea Rook
F3 White's still better here G5
okay sock fish prefers rook
hg1 and then here ah so Rook G1 I guess
gave up my whole Advantage yeah I played
this move pretty quickly thinking it's
just a natural move but the engine
prefers taking and then taking and then
Rook
G1 I guess the difference here
is black has committed the pawn and it
doesn't have time to play Knight F6 and
Knight takes
D5 and okay I guess this is this is
understandable that yeah black is still
suffering with the king in the center
and we're keeping Queens on the board
it's probably not good for black to ever
take at least right
away but okay after Rook G1 seems like
the play was very very clean also very
very
dra and okay so another pretty clean
game um definitely some interesting
moments in the middle game but can't be
too
upset um this puts me at 3 and 1 half
out of seven there are two more rounds
to go so I will admit I'm pretty tired
like this this is one of my longer games
in the tournament I haven't had too many
games exceeding 40 moves so I think it's
time to find some food and hopefully
sleep early
tonight um yeah two more games I am one
point behind Magnus Carlson uh Magnus
has four and a half I have three and a
half so I don't think I'm going to get a
chance to play him but you never know uh
do stay tuned and I look forward to
seeing you guys in the next video adios